[Music]
i don't know how many san francisco fans
are here we're in los angeles
[Applause]
how about red sox fans
[Applause]
really
people would like to say woo
[Applause]
exactly who likes the orlando woos uh
what you you brought your own beverage
we supply beverages yeah yeah uh well
you know i was gonna bring you a bat but
they wouldn't let it on the plane so i
had a bat from uh you know the first
playoff series the cincinnati river
you're gonna give me a world series bat
no no the just the division series
cincinnati reds
that went to the hall of fame
yeah what do you mean what do you mean
why
i grabbed just a wonderful bat i went 0
for 8 with this bat
and that's what you were going to give
me i was like this is perfect you must
have seen one of my monologues
this is my 0 for eight back yeah it
didn't get broken so that was one of my
reasons of choosing it most of the good
bats get broken so what's with the uh
all right well this is an nlcs
championship series uh celebration
bottle i signed it for you
part of this champagne could have been
poured on buster posey's head right or
may not have so basically you're
presenting me
with an empty bottle of champagne
[Applause]
[Music]
some of that champagne that was in there
thank you oh yeah wow thank you very
much though that's very nice you're
welcome national league champion brand
wine um
okay let's talk about i wanted to sip
out of one of these mugs i was like it's
so cool it is the highest high you can
have in life yes this is like you're on
the stage so now let's discuss this
boring world series thing
you just became a world series champ and
you're like i get to sip out of a taco
you got to get your priorities straight
uh let's talk about this there's a play
that fascinates me uh you shattered
a lot of bats in the playoffs you kind
of are known for shattering bats and i
relate because i also hit with great
power um
but there's one play where you hit the
ball so hard the bat shattered and you
actually i think the bat made contact
three different times on the bat the
ball did uh on the bat and it gave it a
special kind of crazy spin that i don't
think i've seen watching baseball let's
take a look at that play
[Applause]
line drive now it sports by cosmo
one run scores sandoval scores
jay drops it in center and they're going
to bring home
posey
and it's five nothing
and watch the ball leave the bat
of hunter pence
it just shattered his bat
that was
you know i saw that play
i saw that plan i thought i don't think
i've ever seen that before
the bat hit the ball three times as it
breaks and then i had this crazy what if
you're so good that the manager said
here's what i want you to do
first of all conan uh uh i i'm sure
you're a big baseball fan but it's not
good when your bat gets shattered that's
not usually not but don't you think in
that instant it maybe it worked out it
worked out great for me you know i like
to joke that it was just a beautiful
path of staying inside the ball
uh but really the pitch kind of beat me
and
some kind of i don't know something
happened where the ball hit my bat three
times and i remember i didn't feel it
when i hit the ball you don't feel like
it's the ball it's happening really fast
obviously so you take you know i take a
swing as hard as i can it just feels
like i broke my bat and when it goes off
my bat i see cosmo goes left and then
the ball starts taking off right and i
was just like
yeah let's let's talk about your running
style
as a player it's really your only
achilles heel
i'll be off now